- En plus, après avoir été
traité ici on doit traiter à
Gatineau. Je m'en passerai.
de l'Abitibi-Témiscamingue
- Si on aurait pu ouvrir avant,
on l'aurait fait, puis c'est
ce qui aurait été souhaitable.
Par contre, je peux dire qu'on
n'a rien à se reprocher dans le
dossier au niveau des stratégies
ou des efforts ont été mis
de l'avant pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse avoir
les ressources nécessaires
dans les temps requis.
- Pour l'APTS, le syndicat qui
représente entre autres les
technologues, cette situation
est une preuve de plus
que l'Abitibi-Témiscamingue
doit avoir accès à des p
supplémentaires du ministère
de la Santé pour être
plus attractive.
CARL VERREAULT, représentant
national, APTS - Abitibi-Témis.
- Au niveau du rec
c'est très difficile, là.
On a seulement deux cégeps
à la grandeur du Québec
qui offrent le programme en
français. Ce n'est pas beaucoup
de technologues qui graduenti g.
Donc, pour la région ici,
ce serait essentiel d'avoir
un atout supplémentaire pour
pouvoir attirer ces jeunes
dans notre région. C'est pour ça
que l'AP également
un statut particulier
pour la région de l'Abitibi-
Témiscamingue.
- Pendant ce temps, l'équipe qui
travaille depuis trois ans
ise en place du centre
de radio-oncologie régional
a elle aussi hâte de recevoir
ses premiers patients.
Dr GEORGES MAKDESSI, Centre de
radio-oncologie régional, R.-N.t
la première visite en 2018,
été 2018, avec la famille,
quand ils ont commencé à parler
du projet. Donc, c'était
un rêve, c'était un rêve
pour moi, pour ma famille
et pour la population.
C'est vraiment... C'est quelqueL
chose, c'est une expérience
très riche.
AUDREY COTTON, cheffe de service
en oncologie régionale
- C'est tellement un grand
accomplissement dans une vie
professionnelle que de pouvoir
ouvrir ce service-là à la
population, que c'est vraime
enrichissant.
- Les efforts de recrutement
se poursuivent au CISSS
de l'Abitibi-Témiscamingue.
On espère être en mesure
de donner les traitements
de radiothérapie
dès juin prochain.